before we move on past the method of
undetermined coefficients i want to make
an interesting and actually a useful
point let's say that i had the following
non-homogeneous differential equation
second derivative of y
minus three times the first derivative
minus four y
is equal to now this is where it gets
interesting
three
e to the two x
plus 2 sine of x
plus
let me make up make sure that i'm doing
the same problems that i've already
worked on plus
4x squared
plus 4x squared
so you might say wow this is a
tremendously complicated problem i have
the three types of functions i've been
exposed to i would have so many
undetermined coefficients it would get
really unwieldy and this is where you
need to make a a simplifying realization
we know the three particular solutions
to the following differential equations
we know the solution to
uh second derivative minus 3 times the
first derivative
minus 4y well this is the homogeneous
right and we know
that the solution to the homogeneous
equation we did this a bunch of times is
c1
e to the 4x
plus c2 e to the minus x
we know the solution to and i'll switch
colors just for variety
y prime prime minus 3y prime minus 4y
is equal to just this alone
3e to the 2x
and we saw that that solution
that particular solution there
y particular was minus one half e to the
2x and we did that you know we did this
using undetermined coefficients we did
that a couple of videos ago
and then let me just write this out a
couple of times
we know the solution to this one as well
this was another particular solution we
found i think it was two videos ago and
we found that this particular solution
in this case and this was a fair a
fairly hairy problem
was minus 5
over 17
x
plus three over seventeen
sorry the particular solution
was minus five over seventeen
sine of x
plus 3 over 17 cosine of x
and then finally this last
polynomial we could call it we know the
solution when that was just the right
hand side
with that that was this equation
and there we figured out and that this
was this was in the last video we
figured out that the particular solution
in this case
was
minus x squared
plus
three halves x
minus 13 over eight
so
we know the particular solution when
zero is on the right hand side we know
it when just three e to the two x is on
the right hand side we know just when 2
sine of x is on the right hand side and
we know it just went 4x squared on the
right-hand side so if we want first of
all the particular solution to this
non-homogeneous equation we could just
take the sum
of the three particular solutions and
that makes sense right because one of
the particular solutions like this one
when you put on the left-hand side it'll
just equal this term
this particular solution when you put it
in the left-hand side will equal this
term and finally this particular
solution when you put in the left-hand
side will equal the 4x squared
and then you could put the homage to add
this homogenous solution to that
you put it in this hands this side and
you'll get zero so it won't change the
right hand side and then you will have
the most general solution because you
have these two constants that you can
solve for depending on your initial
condition so
the solution
to
this seemingly hairy differential
equation is really just the sum
of these four solutions and let me clean
up some space because i want everything
to be on the board at the same time
so the solution
is going to be
well
i want that to be deleted
the solution is going to be i'll do it
in baby blue
it's going to be the solution to the
homogeneous
c1 e to the 4x
plus
c2 e to the minus x
minus one half
e to the two x
and i'll continue this line minus five
over seventeen
sine
of x plus 3 over 17 cosine of x
minus
x squared plus
3 halves x minus 13
over 8.
and it seems daunting when you saw this
it probably looked daunting this
solution if i told you there's a
solution you didn't know how to do
undetermined coefficients you're like oh
i would never be able to figure out
something like that but the important
realization is
that you just have to find the
particular solutions for each of these
terms and then sum them up and then add
them to the general solution for the
homogeneous equation if this if this was
a 0 on the right-hand side and then you
get the general solution for this fairly
fairly intimidating looking
second
order
linear
non-homogeneous differential equation
with constant coefficients
see you in the next video we'll start
learning another method for solving
non-homogeneous equations